en este vídeo vamos a hablar de las
curvas de utilidad marginal y las curvas
de utilidad total aquí tenemos una tabla
que nos muestra la utilidad marginal que
se va obteniendo al conseguir pelotas de
tenis al principio no tengo ninguna
pelota y no puedo jugar tenis así que me
pongo muy feliz cuando consigo la
primera pelota esta pelota me da una
utilidad marginal de 100 pero 100 que
esto es lo mejor acerca de la utilidad
marginal que podemos utilizar unidades
abstractas no vamos a hablar en términos
de dinero o de costo de oportunidad
simplemente tenemos estas unidades
abstractas que si queremos podemos
llamar unidades de utilidad porque lo
que realmente importa es la relación
entre valores luego consigo la segunda
pelota es mucho mejor porque ahora puedo
perder la primera pelota o dejar de ir a
recogerla a cada momento como pasa
cuando juego tenis pero la utilidad que
tengo no es igual a la que obtuve de la
primera pelota la primera pelota me
permitió empezar a jugar tenis con la
segunda pelota ya estoy jugando tenis
mis partidos simplemente van a ser un
poco más agradables entonces podemos
decir que la utilidad marginal
de la segunda pelota es de 80 u 80 por
ciento más en términos de unidades de
utilidad de lo que es la primera pelota
vamos a ponerlo en una gráfica
empezamos marcando estas y veamos qué
aspecto tiene la gráfica entonces la
primera pelota nos da una utilidad de
100 la segunda nos da una utilidad de 80
la tercera observa la tendencia si
trazáramos una recta esta sería una
pendiente negativa estos son valores
discretos pero si quisiéramos unir la
línea podríamos trabajar con media
pelota o tres cuartos de pelota y así la
recta sería continua lo importante es
observar que si conectamos los puntos
esta es una pendiente descendente
entonces tres pelotas nos dan una
utilidad de 64 una utilidad de 45 una
utilidad de 20 el tener cinco pelotas
aún nos reporta un poco de utilidad pero
mis bolsillos ya están llenos y es
difícil jugar tenis con los bolsillos
llenos de pelotas la sexta pelota ya no
me da ninguna utilidad marginal no tengo
donde guardarla y ya no me interesa
tenerla la séptima pelota ya es
negativo es una pelota extra de la que
me tengo que preocupar porque no tengo
donde almacenarla y me está quitando
espacio este es un caso discreto pero
también podemos trabajar con un caso
continuo donde la cantidad sea más
granular por ejemplo kilos de chocolate
o algún producto similar pero en este
caso si conectamos los puntos obtenemos
una pendiente descendente
esta es la curva de utilidad marginal
por lo general todas las curvas de
utilidad marginal son descendentes
porque la utilidad que nos reporta la
primera unidad que consumimos o usamos
siempre será mejor que la siguiente
principalmente porque te cansas de ese
producto o simplemente te empiezas a
quedar sin espacio ya consumiste más de
lo que necesitabas esto concuerda con lo
que aprendimos sobre la ley de la
demanda en la ley de la demanda ante
cada cantidad creciente la gente dice
bueno ya tengo un poco de esto pero la
ley de la demanda no habla de un solo
individuo sino de un mercado sin embargo
un mercado en su totalidad está formado
de individuos y cada uno de estos
individuos puede pensar la primera
unidad de un producto es real
importante para mí la siguiente unidad
está bien pero no la necesito tanto así
que voy a pagar menos por ella y la
siguiente después de esa tampoco está
mal pero voy a pagar mucho menos por
ella este es el comportamiento de todos
los individuos que forman un mercado y
de aquí surge la ley de la demanda estas
son ideas consecuentes y es por eso que
la curva de demanda también tiene
pendiente negativa por lo general en
este eje está el precio en vez de la
utilidad así que podemos pensar en que
el precio es un indicador de la utilidad
por supuesto la cantidad está en este
otro eje entonces esta es la cantidad de
pelotas y esta es la curva de utilidad
marginal pero qué pasa con la utilidad
total vamos a colocar una tabla que
muestre la utilidad total calcular la
utilidad total es bastante sencillo con
la primera pelota la utilidad total es
igual a la utilidad marginal así que
vamos a tener el mismo punto de partida
que es cuando el consumo apenas empieza
la primera pelota tiene 100 unidades de
utilidad y la segunda tiene 80 entonces
la utilidad total de dos pelotas va a
ser 180
lo que estamos haciendo es sumar las
unidades de utilidad marginal de las
primeras dos pelotas para obtener la
utilidad total de tres pelotas a esto le
sumamos esto y esto a 180 le sumamos las
60 unidades de utilidad de la tercera
pelota y ahora tenemos 240 entonces la
tercera pelota nos da una utilidad total
de 240 para cuatro pelotas a 240 le
sumamos la utilidad marginal de la
cuarta pelota esto nos da 280 que en la
gráfica está aquí para la utilidad total
de cinco pelotas a 280 le sumamos la
utilidad marginal de la quinta pelota
que es 20 esto nos da 300 la quinta
pelota nos da una utilidad total de 300
que en la gráfica está por aquí la sexta
pelota no nos da utilidad marginal así
que la utilidad total cuando tenemos
seis pelotas permanece igual da lo mismo
si tenemos cinco o seis pelotas y en la
gráfica esto se ve plano llegamos a la
séptima pelota ya estamos hartos de
tener tantas pelotas de tenis que solo
nos agobian y no se estresan y en
realidad esta pelota tiene una utilidad
marginal negativa por lo que sí
alguien me obliga a tener siete pelotas
de tenis la utilidad total disminuiría
en 20 entonces la utilidad total sería
280 en la gráfica estaría aquí y podemos
poner las utilidades marginales aquí es
esto más 80 esto más 60 esto más 40
luego esto más 20 esto más cero y esto
menos 20 si se dan cuenta son los mismos
números de la tabla de utilidad marginal
ahora bien este ejemplo es un caso
discreto porque no tenemos media pelota
de tenis o una cantidad pi de pelotas de
tenis pero en términos generales si
tenemos un ejemplo continuo y conectamos
los puntos la curva de utilidad total va
a tener un aspecto similar a este lo
interesante es que justo al inicio del
consumo estamos en el mismo punto esto
tiene sentido con la primera unidad
obtenemos una utilidad marginal que va a
ser igual a la utilidad total y está
pendiente será ascendente mientras
obtengamos una utilidad marginal
positiva por cada unidad entonces
mientras las unidades marginales sean
positivas esta gráfica
total va a ir subiendo pero observen que
debido a que aquí las utilidades
marginales disminuyen el incremento de
la utilidad total disminuye y la
pendiente desciende en este punto
podemos ver la utilidad marginal como la
pendiente de la curva de utilidad total
observen que la curva de utilidad total
tiene un valor máximo y empieza a
alcanzarlo aquí en este punto donde la
curva de utilidad marginal llega a cero
esto es porque más allá de ese punto al
menos en este ejemplo la utilidad
marginal es negativa entonces cuando
agregamos la séptima unidad la curva de
utilidad total empieza a descender y
vamos a tener una pendiente negativa nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo